es una visita importante la de los
líderes de francia alemania italia para
reunirse con el presidente ucraniano de
lenski aquí en kiev la guerra de ucrania
ha transformado el panorama geopolítico
internacional la propia alemania ha
aumentado el gasto en defensa el mayor
desde hace 83 años y ha eliminado las
restricciones para exportar armas algo
que no ocurría desde la segunda guerra
mundial sobre la mesa hoy van a discutir
el envío de armas a ucrania alemania
había pactado había prometido varios
envíos que no se han materializado es
algo que le reclama zelinski al
canciller alemán y van a discutir
también sobre el acceso de este país a
la unión europea un camino que se prevé
largo pero no cabe duda que esta visita
refuerza el apoyo de la unión europea a
este país el gobierno ucraniano por su
parte teme que los líderes de francia
alemania italia presionen a cell en ski
para negociar con rusia sobre todo
después de las polémicas declaraciones
de manuel macro donde decía que no había
que humillar a rusia matizó después el
presidente francés añadiendo
que no había que humillar a rusia había
que negociar con rusia eso sí siempre
después de la victoria de ucrania sobre
rusia dando por vencedor a este país
esta visita muestra la solidaridad
europea con este país en un momento tan
complicado donde más de 500 militares
están muriendo al día en la batalla
sangrienta que está ahora mismo
produciéndose en el donbass